des annonces du président très attendue
donc surtout pour certaines professions
notamment médicale en première ligne
face aux copines ou bien encore par
d'autres confronté à des pertes
économiques abyssal elle place à notre
décryptage pour analyser la situation et
pour en parler nous sommes avec pierre
schwab
peignez infirmier aux urgences de
l'hôpital beaujon à clichy membres du
collectif inter urgence bonsoir avec
vous benjamin a marre professeur
d'histoire porte parole cgt 94 bonsoir
également pour décrypter cette actualité
thierry fontaine président de l'uimm mis
à chenilles c'est le principal syndicat
des établissements de nuit
bonsoir bienvenue à tous sur l'antenne
de rtl france alors face à la hausse des
cas l'exécutif s'apprête donc à prendre
de nouvelles mesures
la prise de parole des manuels macron de
demain soir on le disait et très attendu
on évoqua couvre-feu entre autres à
paris ou des réconforts de confinement
dans certaines grandes villes
alors d'abord un petit tour de table si
j'ose dire qu'attendez-vous de la prise
de parole du président de la clarté
thiery font taire on commence avec vous
oui en effet la profession est un petit
peu de clarté de la logique des des
choses que le public peut comprendre
aujourd'hui on a changé de position
plusieurs fois le public c'est plus
c'est plus ça devient compliqué d'aller
dans un café ça devenait compliqué
d'aller au restaurant il ya des gestes
d'hier d'aujourd'hui en termes de
communication c'est un petit peu floue
et même la progression est vrai de la
logique aujourd'hui alors même question
pour vous 20 maamar cette prise de
parole elle doit elle va servir à quoi
sachant que pas de restrictions
concernant les écoles comme vient de
l'annoncer jean michel blanquer
la situation est sous contrôle précise
le ministre de l'éducation
vous attendez quoi vous un jeune amar de
la prise de parole du président demain
écoutez je vais vivre cette espérer je
veux bien mais alors franchement je
n'espère plus rien de se répandre
moi je me souviens j'ai un peu de
mémoire je parle poisson rouge avec 30
secondes de mémoire tampon et je me
souviens très bien des grands discours
avec dédé
et ton comme ça très solennelle des
manuels macron souvenez vous par exemple
de toutes ces histoires selon lesquelles
il fallait mieux payer les premiers de
corvée bah écoutez en l'occurrence allez
donc demander au premier de cordée dans
le nettoyage dans un certain nombre de
secteurs si ils ont vu un euro de plus
sur leur fiche de paye manière générale
je n'attends plus rien de ce
gouvernement où on va on va aller à la
pêche aux informations de manière
factuelle mais je n'attends rien
notamment en matière de cohérence vous
disiez à l'instant que selon le discours
de monsieur blanc caire tout allait bien
dans l'éducation
écoutez dans le monde de monsieur blanc
caire peut-être mais dans le monde réel
celui dans lequel mes collègues et moi
nous travaillons il n'en est rien et la
situation à l'école et je dirais je sais
pas quel adjectif quel qualificatif
utilisé
elle est désastreuse c'est le royaume de
l'opacité c'est le royaume de l'absence
de transparence c'est le royaume
également de l'incertitude et c'est le
royaume d'ubu roi où on raconte je
dirais à la cantonade ce que l'on veut
mais qui ne correspond pas au réel donc
très honnêtement je n'attends rien ce
gouvernement s'est montré désastreux
dans sa gestion sanitaire et à mon avis
il n'y aura rien de nouveau sous le
soleil
on va y revenir sur la situation dans
les écoles mais dans les hôpitaux à
paris qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez vous
pierre schwab
tellier la situation à ce qu'elle est
suffisamment grave pour envisager un
recours finement par exemple alors
heureusement ce n'est pas à moi de
prendre cette décision là et je
laisserais volontiers les gens qui ont
un qui sont responsables de ça et le
faire en tout cas la seule chose que je
peux dire c'est que si le confinement il
ya en tout cas ça sera certainement pas
due à une minorité qui ne respecteraient
pas les gens qui restent les gestes
barrière pardon mais bien l'incapacité
du système hospitalier français
aujourd'hui d'accueillir tout le monde
lors de la première vague on ne
connaissait pas la pathologie on n'avait
pas le matériel on n'avait pas le
capacitaire mais on a eu des renforts
qui ont permis de
ouvrir des lits et de pouvoir contrôler
à peu près cette première vague que très
clairement on n'a pas à gérer mais qu'on
a subies et là pour la deuxième vague
on a peut-être du matériel peut-être
qu'on a plus de protection et qu'on
connaît bien la pathologie en tout cas
on n'a plus du tout personnel et il
reste encore le gros problème du
capacitaire on a absolument pas de
capacité à avoir actuelle pour
accueillir tout le monde à l'hôpital
vous vous attendez une déclaration du
président de la république sur ce sujet
là sur le sujet des effectifs dans le
milieu hospitalier
[Musique]
on attend on attend je pense que ça a
été clair le président de la république
par la boîte de olivier ferrand a fait
un ségur de la santé et ceux ségur de la
santé même s'il se félicite de son
importance continue la caisse de
l'hôpital public le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale qui
va être votée le 15
continuer à demander d 1 milliard
d'économies à l'hôpital public on
continue à supprimer des postes à
supprimer des lits malgré la crise du
corps un virus qui nous touche alors le
contexte économique se tend également on
a vu ces manifestations ce matin enfin
hier pardon de forains des autocaristes
des vtc les intermittents de la
restauration
c'était ce matin sur le périph
pharisiens cette détresse sociale et
économique qui qui s'expriment celle de
seyssel de nombreux français qu'on voit
là finalement benjamin a marre mais bien
évidemment vous savez je suis convaincu
que nous sommes assis sur un baril de
poudre
en réalité la situation sociale elle
était déjà très tendu avant le coc vite
vous souvenez que les gilet jaune
n'avait pas attendu effectivement le
vide pour se manifester voulez vous avez
aussi le souvenir des mobilisations
massives sur les retraites qui n'avait
pas attendu le coc vide sauf que le coc
vide a aggravé la situation
la confédération syndicale des familles
par exemple a effectivement comment dire
pointé le fait que le
je dirais 40% des sondés si je me
souviens bien déclarait avoir perdu
plusieurs centaines d'euros et avoir du
mal à faire face aux dépenses de
première nécessité les field avant les
files d'attentes devant le secours
populaire français par exemple se sont
considérablement allongés cette crise du
coc vide c'est une crise sanitaire et
c'est une crise sociale c'est à dire
qu'en réalité elles exacerbent les
tensions de classe et là quelle est la
réponse du gouvernement par rapport à ça
écoutez je suis le seul à avoir attendu
monsieur véran expliqué que désormais
chaque passage aux urgences qui ne se
solderait par une hospitalisation serez
facturé de deux hits de 18 euros
voilà la réponse du gouvernement et mon
interlocuteur qui est infirmier a tout à
fait raison de pointer comment dire la
situation est scandaleuse
pendant des bois on nous a expliqué
pendant le qu'ovide emmanuel macron le
premier la nécessité de se renouveler
nous avait-il dit moi le premier avait
il rajouté et donc on pouvait s'imaginer
que le fait que l'hôpital public était à
deux doigts de craquer pendant la crise
déco vide eh bien on avait tiré les
leçons que nenni rien du tout et on en
est encore à fermer des lits et on en
est encore effectivement à faire des
chèques en blanc aux grandes entreprises
du cac 40
et rien dans le plan de relance rien sur
le pouvoir d'achat rien sur les salaires
rien effectivement sur les minimas
sociaux je rappelle que ce gouvernement
a refusé de revaloriser le rsa c'est ça
la réalité nous sommes face à des gens
qui sont des apprentis sorciers et ses
apprentis sorciers ils dansent sur un
baril dans un baril de poudre
le 15 octobre il va y avoir une grande
manifestation dans la santé mais le 17
octobre
samedi plusieurs organisations de la cgt
dont la mienne
l'union départementale cgt du val de
marne avec la fédération des services
publics la fédération du commerce les
plus gros union départementale de la cgt
ont appelé à une marche pour la dignité
pour l'emploi va y avoir du monde et
c'est important
c'est très important de faire entendre
la voix de la colère sociale
alors justement thierry fontaine vous
faisiez partie des manifestants ce matin
sur le périphérique lyonnais vous êtes
patron de boîte de nuit à lyon quelle
est votre situation pour qu'on comprenne
bien aujourd'hui la situation la
situation aujourd'hui des entrepreneurs
en france et notamment des boîtes de
nuit qui
fermé depuis sept mois elle est plutôt
dramatique puisque on a eu des promesses
beaucoup n'ont pas touché beaucoup
voient leur outil de travail disparaître
on a déjà 80 de dépôt de bilan c'est
autant de salariés qui vont se retrouver
sans emploi
on s'oriente à 300 dépôt de bilan à la
fin de l'année donc j'imagine est ce que
ça va faire en terme d'emploi c'est
souvent des jeunes et d'un autre côté on
n'a aucune rémunération c'est à dire que
nous on parlait de revalorisation du rsa
on est pour un complètement mais non la
même pas c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui on
vit avec zéro euro depuis le 14 mars qui
est capable en france de vivre avec pas
un euro depuis une période aussi longue
il ya beaucoup de chefs d'entreprise qui
ont des enfants qui doivent scolarisés
ils peuvent les nourrir ils doivent les
chauffe et aujourd'hui doyen toi on va
pouvoir chauffer enfin il ya un minimum
je sais que beaucoup de français sont
dans la détresse
bien sûr que ça nous touche tous les
jours mais là on en train de rajouter à
la pauvreté
toute une profession parce qu'on refuse
de les parler on refuse de trouver des
protocoles des possibilités de sortie de
cette crise et on a eu beaucoup de
promesses en effet mais moi j'ai
beaucoup de professionnels d'un autre
côté qui me disent ce ne sont que des
promesses
on n'a pas touché parce que dans les
décrets ya toujours une petite virgule
la technocratie fait que aujourd'hui
quand on arrive au bout on n'a pas que
pense l'infirmier aux urgences de toute
cette situation comment faire pour
maintenir une activité économique
finalement sang coulait l'hôpital de
l'autre côté pierre schwab tellier moi
personnellement ça fait un an et demi
qu'on en mobilisation n'a pas attendu le
corona des russes pour dénoncer la
situation dans les hôpitaux qui nous
semblait déjà alarmante avant la crise
la crise n'a fait que révéler très
clairement au grand jour ce qu'on disait
depuis le début qu'on n'a pas les moyens
d'accueillir tout le monde aujourd'hui
les choix politiques qui ont été faits
on a eu cinq mois pour se préparer les
choix politiques qui ont été faits n'ont
pas été faits en faveur de l'hôpital
très clairement et on a on n'a pas
d'amélioration en termes de capacité
donc oui c'est oui donc comme disait le
collègue de la cgt le problème c'est que
l'état comme il comme il gère une
entreprise comme l'hôpital il n'a pas
les moyens de répondre à la demande il
va donc il va donc essayer de diminuer
cette demande en faisant payer d'entre
eux en faisant payer les urgences
alors après il ya un gros amalgames on
peut en parler longtemps sur ce forfait
est urgence entre la nécessité
d'hospitalisation et la nécessité de
soins qui sont deux choses totalement
différentes et qui sont un petit peu
insultante en termes de professionnels d
urgence puisque c'est une minorité de
patients qui sont fait qu'ils sont
hospitalisés mais les autres patients
nécessite quand même des soins que c'est
un petit peu insultant envers nous de
nous dire que on s'occupe de gens qui
n'ont pas besoin euro devient à
l'hôpital donc voilà mais non là l'état
continue ça les accords du ségur de la
santé on en a beaucoup parlé dans les
faits ce que voulez vous voyez vous les
voyez les milliards qui ont été posées
produire non car on parle on parle de
trois ans on se fixe sur trois versants
il ya trente trois mesures dans le
secteur de la santé dont
la remise en cause des 35 heures dont la
mise en place de 11 heures de repos
entre deux journées travaillées au lieu
de 12 heures réglementaires
parce qu'on veut favoriser le 12 heures
à l'hôpital parce que c'est plus simple
parce que ça permet de ramener plus de
monde mais voilà mais c'est ça les
mesures du ségur mais en réalité elles
n'auront convaincu très clairement que
les organisations syndicales signataires
les professionnels eux ils ont répondu
ils sont en train de démissionner en
masse 40% des 1 fermé veulent changer de
métier d'après la dernière enquête de
l'ordre national des infirmiers
elle est là la réponse je vous propose
maintenant de s'arrêter sur les
réactions politiques 1 24 heures avant
la prise de parole des manuels macron
est les commentaires sont assez acerbe
comme celui vous allez le voir de la
patronne du rassemblement national
marine le pen regarder ce qui me frappe
depuis le début de cette épidémie
c'est l'absence totale d'anticipation de
la part du gouvernement où est le plan
de gestion de crise on pouvait
éventuellement leur pardonner pour la
première vague
c'est impardonnable pour la seconde
alors absence totale d'anticipation de
la part du gouvernement la critique est
facile d'un jamin a marre vous en
partager le constat non mais moi
j'attends pas l'extrême droite crypto
fasciste pour faire des constats qui
sont factuels
soyons très clairs oui effectivement je
pense que n'importe qui qui n'a pas un
espace vide entre les deux oreilles se
rend bien compte que ce gouvernement est
une brochette de pieds nickelés qui
effectivement ne fonctionne qu'à
l'exercice de qom voilà si on avait des
hommes d'état quel que soit leur bord
politique d'ailleurs si on avait des
gens qui au delà des accents et des
trémolos dans la voix
comment dire prenait la situation à
comment dire à sa juste comme eh bien on
aurait eu des des décisions
je dirais des grandes décisions fortes
qui ne finalement ne remuez pas comme
une girouette
alors on peut partir quand même juste
des chiffres de santé publique france
puisque le gouvernement se fissure santé
publique france qu'est ce qu'on vous dit
et bien que entre les écoles et les
entreprises
on a autour de 60% des clusters voilà et
que les rassemblements publics de
personnes
c'est autour de 8% des clusters donc à
force de croiser ces flics
d autres interlocuteurs a pointé le fait
que effectivement ou stigmatisés comme
ça les rassemblements publics et privés
dans les bars etc
alors qu'en réalité le problème si on
regarde les chiffres de santé public
français a priori c'est là dessus que le
gouvernement seconde on a à l'école elle
dans les entreprises la l'ultra pas la
grande majorité des clusters quoi est
derrière vous l'avez dit vous-même
monsieur gravi monsieur blanc qu'elle
nous dit tout va bien circulez ya rien à
voir
et donc on a un vrai souci on a un vrai
problème effectivement de cohérence vous
avez vu comme moi dans n'importe quelle
grande ville en france la kio
interminable que nous avons eu au moment
devant les laboratoires sur la question
des tests parce que la question des
tests elle a été finalement aussi
lamentablement gérer que la question des
masques voilà donc on a effectivement
une gigantesque impréparation alors
critique également du numéro deux de la
france insoumise cette fois de rien qu'à
tenace regarder quand on voit qu'on ne
peut plus aller au restaurant après 22
heures mais qu'on peut continuer à
s'entasser tous les matins dans les
transports en commun en termes de
circulation de l'épidémie c'est
peut-être plus dangereux que des
restaurants dans lesquels des protocoles
sanitaires strictes sont appliquées
alors c'est vrai qu'on a parfois du mal
à saisir les différents protocoles
sanitaires qui existent un peu partout
qu'en pense le professionnel de santé
pierre schott tellier vous savez on a on
a on a eu cette première vague à
l'origine on nous a dit quand même qu'il
fallait pas porter de masque
donc je me méfie depuis le début des
protocoles sanitaires y compris pendant
la première vague dans les hôpitaux qui
ont été en fonction de la pénurie ou de
l'accès aux en ce moment donc là
maintenant qu'on en a des masses que
tout le monde doit emporter ce
obligatoire sinon c'est la mode
donc voilà je n'ai pas trop d'avis là
dessus c'est pour moi c'est je veux dire
c'est à presse et de la communication
c'est voilà faut faire quelque chose
pour pas être condamnée à ne rien avoir
fait mais on soit le gros problème pour
moi c'est dans l'hôpital on n'a pas les
capacités pour accueillir tout le monde
donc très clairement quoi qu'il fasse
tant qu'ils auront mettront pas des lits
et des moyens à l'hôpital public pour
accueillir de façon optimale la
population sera toujours confronté à ce
genre de choix et on pourra choisir des
responsables vous mettre des boucs
émissaires sur les étudiants ça changera
pas le problème il vous le professionnel
de la nuit ça vous irrite quand vous
voyez c'est métro bondé et puis ces bars
fermés à partir de 22h dans le même
temps alors oui bien sûr que ça mérite
je vais rejoindre je vais pas rentrer
mois sur le sujet médical parce que je
ne suis pas médecin pu tout et surtout
pas essayer de le devenir
en effet il ya des mesures et des
protocoles qui sont stupides on va dîner
en couple dans un restaurant
on est obligé de garder son masque
jusqu'à l'arrivée du premier plat le
remettre entre deux plats l'enlever
après quand on sort on rentre dans la
même voiture on dans le même foyer on va
dormir dans le public
là on est chez nous on comprend pas mais
ce qu'on comprend surtout c'est que plus
on ferme des commerces puis on ferme des
bars puis on ferme des restaurants qui
sont visibles ou l'opinion publique les
vois tous les jour voit les protocoles
voit ce qui est appliqué ou des
professionnels son thème responsable et
raisonnable et font appliquer ces
protocoles
plus on ferme ces établissements plus on
crée une prohibition on crée on fait une
fête super rennes qui en plus pour les
jeunes et plutôt excitante on fait la
fête c'est interdit ça ajoute quelque
part un attrait à cette fête et on se
rend compte que dans ces rassemblements
il ya beaucoup plus de contamination
dans que dans les bars ils sont
multipliées par 3 par quatre par 5
on a vu alors je stigmatise pas du tout
les jeunes au contraire on n'a qu'une
fois 18 ans dans sa vie ces jeunes
pendant quatre ans l'a répété en boucle
qu'il ne craignait rien qu'il ne
craignait absolument rien aujourd'hui
vous leur demander d'être en prison non
c'est pas possible
ces jeunes où vous les mettez dans des
commerces avec des professionnels qui
dans le cadre et on arrive à minima on
vous dit pas qu'il rakovic 0 mais qu'est
ce qu'il vaut mieux qu'ils aient 4
5 4 e vide dans un bar dans une soirée
où qu'ils en aient 70 à 80 au final dans
un regroupement parce qu'il se retrouver
à une centaine dans un appartement qui
ont theuri poteau contenir 10 ils sont
six remplacer il n'y a pas de
ventilation pas de gestes barrières pas
de masque parce que tout le monde se
sent invincible et vulnérable ce qui est
logique on leur a arrêté 1 et au final
bah on a pas 4 contamination mais on
aura ce compte 60 c 50 60
potentiellement vont contaminer des plus
anciens et c'est ça qui va créer une
charge à l'hôpital
si la méthode de gouvernement avait été
la bonne je pense pas qu'aujourd'hui on
naviguerait entre 12 et 20 mille cas
positifs testé par jour je pense qu'on
serait plus tôt peut-être à trois quatre
cinq mille mais là je pense que c'est
beaucoup
si en effet la logique du gouvernement
était d'arriver à la c'est une réussite
s'il voulait on continue à maintenir un
qu'ovide son capital soit surchargé
alors on peut clairement dire que c'est
un échec
clairement alors pour finir il nous
reste deux minutes ce chiffre également
45 % des salariés se sentent plus
fatigués physiquement et
psychologiquement qu'avant la crise du
coc vide à c'est le résultat d'une
enquête ifop 1 publié ce mardi on va
sortir dans quel état de cette crise
benjamin a marre ou alors là moi je suis
extrêmement optimiste je vous le dis que
son jeu notre société était une société
en tension avant le coc vide
le coc vide et la gestion calamiteuse du
gouvernement à exacerber cette situation
moi je à votre question est générale
mais moi je vais juste là concentrée sur
mes collègues
les enseignants en prend effectivement
le comment dire la communication et la
gestion très aléatoire du ministre et la
fatigue que provoque le fait de faire
cours en permanence avec des masques
avec des élèves qui fatalement sont tous
indisponibles
et bien moi mais mes collègues me disent
que quand ils rentrent chez eux ils
tournent de sommeil ils sont épuisés
c'est extrêmement compliqué et ce qui va
là pour les enseignants est valable pour
beaucoup de professions on a finalement
eu une incertitude une inquiétude
sanitaire qui se double d'une inquiétude
sociale enfin me rappelle quand même à
là on est
les premiers les prévisions de l'unedic
c'est un million d'emplois détruits
d'ici la fin de l'année
ça fait lourd ça fait lourd et quand on
a en face un gouvernement aussi
finalement aussi inconsistant et bien
j'ai l'impression qu'on a tous les
ingrédients pour un cocktail explosif et
vous les soignants dans quel état pour
affronter cette seconde vague les
bouteilles les soignants quand je vous
ai dit tout à l'heure on a une dernière
il ya eu une heure une enquête qui a
montré qu'ils avaient 40 % des
infirmiers qui voulaient carrément
changer de métier on a un gros problème
quand on s'appelle en termes de nombre
de personnels beaucoup de départs
beaucoup de personnes qui refusent de
refaire du coc vide puisque c'est des
sacrifices c'est pour certains ça a été
de ne plus voir ses enfants pendant près
de deux mois donc c'est quand même un
sacré sacrifices n'ont en réalité où on
est toujours au même point c'est à dire
c'est que l'hôpital public paye les la
gestion économique de ces dix dernières
années
aujourd'hui on sait qu'on est tous enfin
on sait qu'il ya beaucoup de personnel
hospitalier dans la fonction publique
hospitalière qui sont proches de la
dépression une proche du burn out
les enquêtes de santé au travail le
montre mais en même temps l'hôpital
public est incapable d'y répondre
simplement parce qu'on a pu le médecin
du travail
on n'a plus du tout de visite de
médecins du travail ça fait neuf ans je
travaille de nuit j'ai jamais faite
visite de la médecine du travail
on est incapable d'avoir un suivi
quelconque sur les prés style
hospitalier parce que voilà c'est au
pire et s'en vont merci à tous les trois
d'avoir accepté notre invitation en
direct sur rtl france merci pierre
schwab tellier infirmier aux urgences de
l'hôpital beaujon à clichy membres du
collectif interurbain ans mercy avoue
benjamin amar porte parole cgt 94
merci à vous tirer fontaine président de
l'uem ih nuit c'est le principal
syndicat des établissements de nuit